quitte ou double pour gilbert couturier
celui qui a remporté il ya six ans les
élections municipales dès sa première
candidature a donc décidé de poursuivre
sa tâche
après un premier mandat dédiée à
l'installation des projets le deuxième
s'il a lieu devrait permettre de passer
à la phase exécutoire et des chantiers
sont multiples les grilles ou avec le
diagnostic de fouilles archéologiques
nous a demandé de combat le faire et
puis ensuite passer à l'exécution
le groupe scolaire de bagatelle pour
l'école mr mr b liste c'est ainsi que
l'école la fraîcheur avec un budget d'un
million trois cent quatre mille euros ou
ses centres sont financées par les par
l'état ensuite nous allons travailler
sur à côté de la cité j'ai continué à
travailler sur l'éducation sur nos
enfants sur les parents mais aussi ne
pas écarter l'idée d
les personnes âgées s'ajoute à cela le
projet de palais de la convergence lieu
destiné aux activités associatives et
culturelles
un premier mandat qui n'a pas été de
tout repos pour gilbert couturier des
absences répétées des élus de sa
majorité
une opposition quelques fois en position
de force quoi qu'il en soit le maire
sortant qui devrait une fois encore
bénéficié du soutien du mime et de celui
du palima pour ces élections semble
aborder cette campagne dans la plus
grande sérénité
[Applaudissements]